if you miss the days or games like
Diablo or baldur's gate reign supreme in
the PC world fear not because indie
developer think trunk is bringing us all
back to the 90s with their upcoming
series entitled return to games seven
games are planned for the series each
completely different from the last but
with their 90's pc game inspiration
being the connective tissue that holds
them all together the first game in the
series is called book of demons a
card-based hack and slash through the
depths of hell the game itself is
heavily inspired by old PC dungeon
crawlers but there are enough modern
touches that make it feel refreshing to
play in the genre where almost every
other game is trying to emulate the
success of Diablo it's nice to see a
game that comes along and tries to do
something a little bit different the art
style alone is worth mentioning with its
papercraft theme income seen almost
every part of the game characters items
buildings and even the UI are cleverly
designed in a pop-up book style which
the game dubs the paper verse the
environments have a satisfying depth to
them and the unique presentation of the
game saves it from any immediate
comparisons to Diablo or torchlight
because at the very least nothing looks
quite like it
jumping right into the game you'll
notice that you'll be able to choose the
length of your journey the game's levels
are procedurally generated so if you're
short on time you can finish an area in
about five minutes but if you've got the
whole weekend to play you can expand it
to 10 15 minutes or even longer if you
want but one thing that is immediately
apparent when you start the game
regardless of the length of the quest
you choose is that your character is on
a fixed path you can move throughout the
dungeons on your own but only on the
lane that the game designates for you
this may sound like a terrible decision
as most people play dungeon crawlers for
the adventuring aspect but it allows the
game to get creative with how it
presents enemies to you attacking
monsters only takes a single click of
the mouse but when facing a large number
of them you won't be able to just run in
guns blazing you'll need to be
methodical about who you take out and
win unless you get blindsided by a
couple of fireballs thankfully the game
has a fairly robust card-based skill
system so you always have the right
tools to vanquish your foes and trust me
there's no shortage of enemies in this
game the deeper and deeper you dive into
the dungeons the more numerous and more
dangerous they become and even though
the game eases you into learning each
one other attacks and how to counter
them it's still quite a challenge when
you're dealing with a room full of
monsters all at once and it all
culminates in each levels boss battles
which are really the stars of the show
simple but layered in complexity bosses
will test your abilities to multitask
you'll have to manage numerous enemies
magical spells and various different
attack phases in order to defeat them
it's a satisfying experience from one
end of the dungeon to the other and with
three different classes to try out it'll
surely keep players busy for a while
book of demons is bound to entice
newcomers to the genre as well as long
time action RPG fans who have been
longing for a different kind of dungeon
crawler the classic gameplay combined
with the fresh visual look and the
variable difficulty setting promises to
appeal to both ends of the spectrum the
game will be released on steam's early
access platform starting july 28 and
although developer think trunk does plan
on making six more games in the same
vein as book of demons it's no doubt
that they're off to a great start
do you think book of demons and the
return to game series could be a start
of something big tell me what you think
of the game in the comments below and
consider subscribing to gamespot for
more coverage thanks for watching and
I'll see you all next time